Russia and the West what divides us what
unites us in the interview Russian
writer Victor yellow fail victorville
near us Victor you've been a harsh
critic of Russia's role in the Ukraine
crisis President Putin met this week
with Western leaders in France for the
first time since the escalation of the
crisis inugami says that he also met
with US President Barack Obama what's
your assessment is it a step towards
reconciliation he met with Obama and
poroshenko but that is not a
conciliatory gesture there's a Russian
saying that seeing one swallow doesn't
mean it's summer but there is movement
and I'm pleased at that we observe the
revolution that unfolded on the my done
but events in Donetsk were altogether
different so much bloodshed and what the
violence must stop first and foremost
and if politicians work to stop the
bloodshed then I'd see that as success
at least a step forward Vash man your
newest science fiction novel akumu d is
almost like a prophecy of recent events
in Crimea and eastern Ukraine it's as if
you predicted everything it's horrifying
so much so that I sometimes think I
should stop writing books I just
returned from Poland where a play has
been produced based on my book people
there believe I'm a profit but I don't
want to play that part still I do feel
some kind of supernatural force in 1984
I wrote a story called the pocket
apocalypse it's been published in
Russian and German
it prophesized the perestroika movement
the conflict in Ukraine and the Crimea
problem cackling gotcha what real value
does Russia place on Ukraine why did
Ukraine of all countries spark this
conflict such a cool medium that's a
vast topic let's simplify it it is a
conflict of values Ukraine as a whole
has been more and more influenced by the
West Western Ukraine has always been
allied with Poland Austria and Hungary
so there is a colossal Western influence
but over the past few years that
influence essentially stopped in Kiev
eastern Ukraine is drawn more to Russian
values which are very different than in
the West Western leaders refuse to
recognize this cultural split eastern
Ukraine and Russia believe citizens
should serve the state with all their
being the individual is essentially
enslaved by the state Western values see
the state as an instrument of the people
that's the crux of the matter would you
that's the West been too naive in its
dealings with Russia as the Cold War
came to a close were expectations too
high that Eastern and Western Europe
would merge you need self bhosle I can
China hallowed nearly yes there is a lot
of naivete but also a basic lack of
knowledge the West simply doesn't have a
solid working knowledge of Russia
watchin as perestroika began it raised
unrealistic expectations for Russia's
future and Western governments initially
placed a lot of trust in Putin that's
especially true of Germany they based
that trust on the fact that he spoke
German and had an affinity for German
culture but the reality was very
different on the day that Putin took
power it became clear that crimea's
future hung in the balance he simply
waited for the best time to strike and
seized Crimea that's clear a lot of
people say that shouldn't happen in the
21st century but who says Russia has
reached the 21st century today Russia
still lives in the seventeenth
eighteenth and nineteenth perhaps the
20th century as well so many Soviet
Communist structures are still in place
and there is little 21st century
influence the archaic primitive values
are much the same as in an African
village they're entrenched and the
citizens are not ashamed of that by
finnivus most Russians do support the
Kremlin's policies opinion polls show
around eighty percent support you've
characterized the Russian people are
strange why does it because the people
have no conceptions of the problems
they're creating that's true of the
government as well
they didn't annex some uninhabited
island in the middle of the ocean they
seized a major piece of territory right
in the middle of Europe and for the
moment they're celebrating but it comes
at the expense of an enormous amount of
trust in the long run the cost of Crimea
will be very high ocean blue could be
kakka bees need to poverty how do you
explain putin's behavior in this
conflict and on the world stage as a
whole what is his driving ambition
Warmack hear it you should put that
question directly to President Putin but
since that's not possible let's put
ourselves in his shoes he broadly
rejects Western values despite that the
West put an immense amount of trust in
him especially Germany it's only reason
for improving relations with the West
was to fulfill Russian interests the
need for technology and modernization
but he will always defend the basic
Russian understanding of life death and
religion as has been done for centuries
and now Putin is offended he's easily
offended he was outraged when the West
supported the Russian opposition
movement at first everyone gave him hugs
miracle kissed him and they talked but
then Germany voiced support for the
protestors Putin probably wished he
could ship them all off to detention
camps or prison so he decided to turn
his back on the west and began building
his own empire he sought closer ties
with China the West has failed to
understand that he truly feels that he's
been betrayed he thought he'd won
friends and allies
we both flew and then they turned on him
and supported a protest movement that
was trying to topple him from power so
he turned his back on the west and
sought new allies all the while dreaming
of a Russian Empire and then along comes
Ukraine and says we want nothing to do
with your empire NASA Putin does have
Western supporters chorus poor Tina
especially right and left-wing opponents
of globalization opinion tougher lava
lizard see much Donna oh we had a
turning point will Putin become the
leader of an international
anti-democratic movement bug la vez fled
even I'm putting him away no Putin would
never accept a ragtag coalition of right
and left-wing groups but Moscow has
officially expressed its congratulations
for French nationalist marine lepen
she's seen as an ally of Russia's
emerging nationalist ideology Europe is
weak at the moment and that's why it was
so easy for Putin to strike a major blow
Europe simply hasn't come up with a
unified response to the annexation of
Crimea it's easy to criticize Russia it
has no clear political agenda and the
nation operates outside the rule of law
Plus Putin is a former KGB officer but
the West refuses to recognize its own
weaknesses Russia's nationalistic
ideology has exposed them so they're
looking at alliances with European
nationalists the two sides have extended
hands of friendship
you cut from crashed on what can the
West do to integrate Russia Korean about
saucer I see you don't suppose the West
must first gain a better understanding
of Russia the things I'm saying here may
make Western leaders scratch their heads
they view Russia as a filthy back room
in the European villa you do they think
they can go in with a vacuum cleaner and
mop everything up and everything will be
fine in fact Russia is another house
altogether it's next door but it stands
alone that's the key failure of
understanding the West urgently needs to
gain a new understanding of Russia and
then find the right method to force
Russia to uphold its international
obligations you can't kick Russia or
criticize it or spit on it that makes it
even stronger more violent and
aggressive and more isolated russia
survived in isolation for almost a
century sanctions don't frighten Russia
they're a source of pride they
invigorate the Russian soul very good
Victor thank you for your time